fox news alert a capitol hill police
officer dead
another injured after a knife-wielding
driver
rammed his car into them chad pergram
has the latest
chad here at the capitol a suspect is
noah green
he is dead he came up to capitol hill
around one o'clock
and rammed his car over two capitol
police officers and then
into a security barrier he jumped out of
the car wielding a large
knife that's when he was shot at and
killed by u.s capitol police officers
the dead officer is billy evans he is a
17-year veteran
of the u.s capitol police house speaker
nancy pelosi says that evans was a quote
martyr for democracy we also have a
statement here from the senate minority
leader mitch mcconnell he says on this
good
friday i would ask that all americans
pray for healing
for the surviving injured officer
remember there were two
who were attacked here for comfort of
officer evans family and for all
officers and families of our u.s capitol
police now in just the past couple of
moments
we have gotten a statement from
president biden about this he says quote
we send our heartfelt condolences to
officer evans family and everyone
grieving at this loss
we know what a difficult time this has
been for the capitol and everyone who
works there
and those to protect it biden has
ordered flags to be flown
at half-staff in honor of officer evans
and house speaker nancy pelosi has
ordered the same
here at the u.s capitol the acting u.s
capitol
excuse me the acting washington d.c
police chief robert conte
says that there appears to be no nexus
to terrorism with this attack at the
capitol
and note that constitution avenue the
access point to the u.s capitol
this was blocked off juan just two weeks
ago until they brought
this outer perimeter of fencing which
they installed after the 1-6
riots in closer to the capital had that
fencing still been up
two to three blocks out from the capitol
this incident wouldn't have happened or
not
at that location juan
chad thanks so much we're going to be